alors que les habitants de la péninsule
sont confinés depuis le 10 mars dernier
le nombre de contaminés et de décès
enregistrés quotidiennement augmente
chaque jour près d'un demi-millier de
morts pour la seule journée de mercredi
plus du double du même jour la semaine
précédente à bergame en lombardie
la première des régions européennes
touchées par le virus
les hôpitaux et les morgues sont
surchargées dans ses camions militaires
une soixantaine de cercueils en route
pour les crématoriums des municipalités
voisines bergame où le chef du
département de médecine de l'hôpital
pape jean xxiii a lancé un appel à
l'aide ce jeudi nous sommes en pleine
urgence avec cette pandémie de
coronavirus autres personnels de santé
infirmières et médecins travaillent 24
heures sur 24 sans compter leurs heures
pour lutter contre cette situation
incroyable we do nord nous ne savons pas
combien de temps cette pandémie va durer
will last nous avons désespérément
besoin d'infirmières et de médecins
elle faisait ainsi que deux ventilateurs
et de dispositifs de protection et
l'italie est loin d'en avoir terminé
avec l'épidémie initialement prévue
jusqu'au 3 avril
le chef du gouvernement giuseppe konté a
annoncé un prolongement du confinement
de l'ensemble du pays
les mesures que nous avons prises tant
celles qui ont entraîné la fermeture
d'une grande partie des entreprises et
des activités individuelles dans le pays
que celle concernant l'école ne peuvent
être que prolonger à leurs échéances
les italiens devront demeurer confiné
plus longtemps et dans des conditions
que certains responsables politiques
veulent plus sévère le président
d'emilie romagne a par exemple signé ce
mercredi une ordonnance limitant les
déplacements au seul réseau médical de
travail ou pour aller faire ses courses
excluant de fait la promenade ou les
activités sportives en plein air des
recommandations similaires ont été
formulées par le gouverneur de la
vénétie voisine qui propose même d'aller
plus loin qu'une simple interdiction de
sortie
contrôler les personnes leurs mouvements
grâce au téléphone portable pour
vérifier le respect des règles contre
les coronavirus serait une excellente
solution mais des règles légales sont
nécessaires car il s'agit de fait d'une
limitation de la vie privée et comme
ailleurs sur la planète
les italiens guette le pic de
propagation de l'épidémie un pic dont la
date est encore incertaine l'université
de gênes avance une date comprise entre
le 23 et le 25 mars le conseil national
de la recherche quant à lui prévoit une
stabilisation du nombre de personnes
infectées
entre le 25 mars et le 15 avril mais
tous reconnaissent l'incertitude liée à
de telles prédictions
le pire est passé dans les premiers
foyers d'infection comme à coloniaux par
exemple où plus aucun cas n'a été
enregistré depuis le 14 mars mais une
augmentation du nombre de contaminés est
toujours en cours dans la région du sud
où son parti de nombreux italiens du
nord que l'épidémie atteigne son pic
dans une semaine ou dans un mois
l'italie doit s'attendre à au moins
plusieurs centaines de morts d'ici là et
davantage encore une fois l'épidémie
terminée